[Music]
either and welcome to this second video
in this series on how to get from ideas
to execution to finished polish peace
I'm Cameron I'm the guy behind motion
science and I decided to put together
this training series because I wanted to
show you how I go about this process how
I go through this workflow to create
from idea to execution I get asked all
the time how I do it and that's why I've
created this short training series to
explain to you how my process works if
you didn't see the first video I would
suggest that you stop this video right
now and you go back and watch video
number one you'll see it I start with
that I start with the creative brief I
start with how I start looking for a
reference and inspiration how I start
putting a simple design together and
that's where we're at right now I'm
going to turn off the audio here and
that's where we're at we're up with this
very basic designed element piece now
this is I would call this a rough rough
design this is not something where I
would say hey here's a client here's my
design for you check it out no we're
gonna continue to define to design and
refine this piece and make it even more
interesting to look at if you don't know
who I am my name is Cameron I'm the guy
here motion science I talked about in
the first video more of my background
but I am NOT taught by art school I did
not go to art school I didn't go to
college for degree in motion design when
I was at college which I was learning
there for one semester they didn't even
teach motion as I'm back then so that
was late 90s I am self-taught I have
spent many many years two decades
teaching myself how to design and
animate in the most ideal way possible
for me and that's what I teach in motion
science so here we are let's jump right
in let's start making this come alive
and
look more interesting so the first I'm
going to do is last time we created
these elements which I'm clients take
our geometry so let's just animate them
and it's real simple to animate them all
we're going to do is we're just going to
open up our contents here and our group
and we're just going to say we want to
use trim paths and trim paths are a
great way to animate inside of After
Effects with shape layers all I do is
set a keyframe for the end point and
I'll go to the beginning and I'll say I
don't want this to be 0 I want or I
don't want it to be hundred percent I
want to be 0 so you can see because this
is filled and not a stroke it looks
really weird how it draws it on now for
some instances maybe this works for you
this is not gonna work for what I want
to do so what I want to do is I want to
select my layer go to fill I want to
turn it off and I want to go to stroke
and I am going to turn it on if I can do
that
I'm actually I'm going to open up the
contents here and we are going to
there's our fill so we're gonna add a
stroke so where is our stroke there it
is boom stroke and you can see you know
there's some space in between the stroke
so that I'm not you know it it may work
for you it may not let's just go ahead
increases slightly so it's kind of
filled in there so there are five maybe
a sassy a little bit of a dot up in here
it's not filled in so let's go six there
we go and now if we look at the trim
pass it draws it on in an interesting
way so I could kind of play around with
this more with the trim path I could say
individually draw them on and it's gonna
draw them on like that but I think for
now simultaneously it's cool because
it's just kind of random and it looks
cool so that's what we're gonna do for
this very very simple so I'm gonna jump
in to sacred go1 which is this guy right
here and this is the one that we redrew
inside of After Effects here and it's
the same thing I'm just going to
open up these one at a time we'll start
with lines we'll say add trim paths and
I miss a keyframe 100% and I'm gonna go
to the beginning here and I'm going to
just take it down to zero and I'm just
gonna go through these one by one
contents trim paths and with anything as
you know you can animate any element you
know however you see fit
I think trim pass works great for this
example so that's all I'm doing
trying to keep this very very simple so
that you understand what I'm doing here
but you can see that simple you know it
doesn't have to always be overly complex
I see a lot of motion designers that
approach a projects
approach projects and they over
complicate things and when you start to
immediately over complicate things that
throws you off from their own so we
start with a project and it's already
over complicated like where do you go
from there right you're like super you
get frustrated you you kind of shut down
you don't you don't know where to go and
you know your project ends up dead or
looking crappy and you're not happy with
this so start simple very simple just
start some so there we go so I head and
on the keyboard hit zero to preview
there we go there is our very very
simple animation that's all we need okay
so if I play this back my music is
turned off you can see those are the two
pieces they hand them a toe on there's
the other one so for this last one I
don't want to see it drawn again
so we'll go past the animation maybe
just somewhere in there and start there
and what we could do for this is maybe
just make it rotate alright so obviously
it's just real simple we'll do 30
degrees
so now we see this just kind of rotate
again very basic but it works now
looking at this one versus this one this
now it feels way too thick to me okay so
I'm looking at the line thickness and so
let's just go back into this layer and
let's just drop it down to two how does
that look closer maybe let's go to one
okay so that's looking a little bit more
interesting so now let's add even more
interest to this let's add a camera okay
and I'm not gonna get into all this
stuff about 3d cameras if you haven't
seen my series on the 3d camera
techniques I definitely invite you to
check that out you can find out on
YouTube but it goes into a lot of detail
about how to work with 3d cameras inside
of After Effects so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to create a bunch of
3d cameras okay I'm gonna start with
this first one and I'm gonna make this
first set three dimensional and I'm
gonna select my camera hit P for
position set a keyframe and let me just
tell you very quickly you'll notice that
I did not use a two node camera a lot of
the animators used to no cameras I
prefer one node I feel like I to me
they're much easier to control that's
why I work with them so I'm gonna go
here I'm gonna hit C on my key to do a
zoom in and I'm just gonna push in on
this guy right so maybe something in
there now let's make it let's make it a
pretty dramatic move so there we go
so if I hit n on the keyboard and just
preview this you know very basic zoom
out a little bit here
I'm just looking for like an interesting
move now you can see immediately that
the background is not moving so it
throws us off so let me make that
background and I'll change this to
background texture I'm gonna make it 3d
as well and let's scale it up even more
and there we go
so now we've got the kind of this trippy
thing going on the you know this design
here in the middle feels a little bit
big to me when it gets to this we get to
this point but all they've it there for
now
next we're gonna move on to the scene
too and you can see that I like to stack
scenes so that they I can I can tell
where each scene is so this is you know
these two layers stop you're seeing one
so we've got two layers here this is
scene two and you can see it helps me
keep things a little bit more organized
you could go in you could start color
changing these different layers and
that's gonna help to keep even more
organization going on but this works for
me for now so what I'm going to do is I
want to duplicate this camera bring it
up here and I'm gonna hit P for position
I'm gonna delete that keyframe but I'm
gonna start here and I am going to make
this camera move side to side we're
gonna keep these moves pretty pretty
simple let's make Nina three-dimensional
and let's make the sacred geo behind her
three-dimensional as well and we're
gonna go to number two here and we're
just going to slide along like so and
like I said this is where I want
something else interesting to happen so
if I slide them a scale this up even
more
moving along maybe a little bit more and
I'm just hitting C on the keyboard to
change my camera controls and here I'm
just gonna do a very simple
pushing just kind of really focus in on
that name I'm go to the end of the scene
here and I'm just gonna make it fly up
like so so if I hit zero I'm gonna see
what this looks like
yeah very cool now one thing I do want
to see is I want the secret geo behind
to be larger so I'm gonna increase the
size here something like that so I'm
looking at this inner circle kind of
containing the type inside of it here
and you know Nina gates this may be too
small but for now I'm going to go ahead
and leave it how it is so there we go
perfect okay so this shot you know maybe
this one doesn't need a 3d camera or
maybe it does actually let's go ahead
and let's just duplicate that first
camera bring it up here and for this
what p4 position maybe let's do
something vertical again so let's make
these three-dimensional actually able to
make the grid wall three-dimensional and
we will move I don't know something like
this now you can see the background
moving the text isn't so now it looks
weird again so let's make those
three-dimensional as well awesome
and for this one let's duplicate again
drag this camera over P for position and
let's do a little trick here so if I hit
proportional grid you're gonna see we've
got nine blocks here okay this is the
rule of thirds okay so I've got how I
did this was I went into my preferences
go into grids and guides and I said oh
my guides my proportional grid sorry I
know my guys my proportional grid I want
a 3x3 what that does is it sets up three
horizontal and three vertical that
creates our rule of thirds for how we
design things okay
typically this spot up here is always
gonna be where our eye goes to first
second third and fourth okay if you were
to break these up now things are always
gonna be you know in focus right here in
the center things will be in focus here
but these are proportional grids to help
us align things for design to help us
make things look better or pleasing to
our eye so what I want to do here is I
want to make Gena three-dimensional and
I want to make her kind of focused in
here okay and then what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to turn off my keys and I'm
gonna do something maybe she's rising to
this spot here now I do have to watch
out because this shot before I'm moving
vertically downwards and now I'm sudden
it's you know it's the same kind of
movement again the next thing that's a
different speed so we have to kind of
watch these kind of things kind of pay
attention to it but what we can do here
again I'm moving quickly here you know
when I go and play back this this motion
it's going to tell me if things are
working or not working so let's go back
to this position turn this off and let's
make Tobey three-dimensional and let's
bring Tobey up in there let's bring him
up here and let's do something
interesting with this one we're kind of
like stutters like maybe a stutter move
so hold the keyframe I right-click and
set a hold keyframe what that does is
that just keeps your key your your a
position right there where it's at until
I move the camera again so I'm gonna hit
the
and we're just gonna make Toby
everything kind of slide to the right so
I'm gonna hit page down and page down
I'm just doing totally random moves here
okay
you know what's gonna move through this
make it move a little bit more here have
a bigger jump and we're just gonna make
it all go off-screen so if I preview
this you're gonna see what happens here
since these are all hold keyframes watch
what happens
very jerky kind of stutter II feel to it
it's a step you feel again I make sacred
Geo
stoners actually run keep it where it is
that's kind of different so what I do
now is I would back all this up and I
would preview the whole thing with audio
here
[Music]
so it's starting to look more
interesting right from where we started
but let's create a little bit of
parallax okay and parallax means that
different valleys different layers 3d
layers are offset right so if I change
this from one view to two views so now
I've got my top view here so maybe let's
go to a left view here's our camera
here's our key frames
here is our back texture or actually
that's our sacred geometry and then if I
select back texture you can see they're
both on the same plane here okay so
let's just say let's bring let's take
sick let's take let's move the
background let's move it back okay so
I'm selecting Z I'm moving it back if
you look in this window here you're
gonna see it moving back as well and all
I'm doing here is I'm as some creating
some separation okay I like to typically
work I'm kind of a DD with with my
numbers I like to have things even
number so I'm gonna make this a thousand
I'm gonna scale it back up so it fills
the frame so there we go and then I am
going to also bring the sacred geometry
I'm going to let's let's bring it in the
middle so let's make it 500 so now we've
got our texture back here at a thousand
we've got our sacred geometry at 500 and
we've got our text at zero okay
I'm gonna select this first instance of
sacred geometry here in the first scene
I'm gonna move it back 500 as well and
then let's go to our last instance here
and we need to let's make it 3d and
let's make it 500 as well and then what
else we have we have our code our hacker
text here which we could make it let's
just say we'll take it back in space to
500
and we'll make this one 500 and now
let's go back to one view here and let's
preview this and you know you can't tell
a lie it so it's a very subtle change
but you can see that the text is moving
in a different rate specifically then
the background is
[Music]
so it's definitely getting much more to
look at
one thing that's really bugging me from
watching this is we start with Nina
gates being centered so let's say that
she's a little bit more important she's
the first name so she is it's okay to
have her centered this version of Gena
block works really well I like how she's
offset this one with Toby being back
centered again I don't like so I'm gonna
take Toby and I am going to
bring Toby down on this line in here
like so and then I'm also going to take
this sacred geometry and be I don't like
just seeing that entire piece of sacred
geometry in the screen it's okay to like
you know cut graphic elements off we
don't have to always see a hundred
percent of the graphic elements so if I
take the scale here and I just scale
this guy up you know maybe something
like that maybe it's just something
we're seeing
I'm just pieces of it and I'm also going
to go ahead and just drag it down so
maybe we're just seeing the top part of
it
and you know when we were doing previews
like this and things aren't real time I
actually really enjoy this part of the
process as it's loading the preview into
my memory here on the computer because I
can see things you know frame by frame
by frame and I can actually start to
notice things more versus in real time
[Music]
okay so something else I've seen is I
you know this seeker geometry I looked
like the way it draws on but it draws on
too quickly we have a lot more time here
for to draw on so let's just double
click here let's select everything but I
think command a I am on a Mac I'm
hitting you on my keyboard and I'm just
going to go ahead and drag this out so
it just takes a little bit longer to get
there
and looking at this first scene I think
it might be interesting to flip this guy
around so let's rotate them 180 degrees
so now he's upside down a little bit
more interesting to look at maybe even
scale this guy up a little bit here and
I'm just nudging with my arrow keys
you
[Music]
awesome really digging this I don't like
how we see part of the texture over here
so I'm actually gonna scale up again the
ball let's say 4:30 and let's just nudge
it with our arrow keys
just kind of bring them over here so
it's just off the edge there and make
sure that this textures taking care of
everywhere else here except for this
final scene I think it's gonna be
interesting to see the texture kind of
fly off the screen here okay so it's
starting to come alive so now let's do
something where we add some lights and
by adding lights to this we're gonna add
some more texture to this to the overall
design of it so we'll do let's see here
let's do a spotlight that's ok we'll do
cache shadow sure and click OK and there
we go so we've got some interesting
lighting going on already one thing I'm
gonna go ahead and turn off my
proportional grid here one thing I do
want to do is I want to make sure that
this sacred geometry here cast shadow so
I'm gonna hit a on my key keyboard and
I'm gonna go down here I must say okay
are you casting shadows no you're not
it's set to OFF let's turn it on there
we go so we've got some interesting
shadows being cast here which may or may
not work you know like I said I try
these things sometimes they work
sometimes they don't we'll go to the
next scene let's see the same thing
let's do another new light and we'll do
a spotlight again I like to work with
spotlights and with point lights those
are the ones I find myself working with
the most let's see where we got here so
this one's really blowing out the scene
and that is because where we at here
and that's because this first spotlight
is being carried over into the scene I
like to work with individual lights if
I'm working with like what I call
individual scenes which is what these
are okay so here we have the next light
and we are going to go into Nina and
we're gonna turn on cash shadows for
Nina there she is
works for me sacred gio we're gonna cast
some shadows there as well that's
interesting you know now I'm looking at
this things it may not work with the
secret geo because I want the sacred geo
to actually be kind of part of the
background the part of the background
texture and with it casting a shadow
it looks like it's separated so much so
we're actually gonna go back in here and
we're going to turn off the cast shadows
mm-hmm and sometimes it can be
interesting to also cast shadows and
different or have a spotlight be a
different color and let me show you so
like since this is called a red robot if
I was to make this light you know more
on the red tone I don't have to be like
you know we don't want to be solid red
like this like there are times where
this could work but you know just kind
of more and that kind of like pinkish
tone something like that it's kind of
interesting I also like to play around
with lights like I said if a spotlight
maybe is not quite right and I want to
try make you an appointment like how
this part of the sacred geometry is so
dark though so a way to fix that is to
bring the cone angle up right something
like so and maybe even bringing the
light a little bit further away so
that's gonna create like a harder shadow
on the background there
interesting so maybe something like so
we duplicate this one so this one seems
to be working pretty well and I'll bring
it on to this next scene here so now
we're losing some of that hacker text
you can tell that it's not quite as
visible anymore so something like this
maybe I'd go in and I'll turn change it
to overlay so now it's a little bit
darker in there I might also go in and
try changing the color of the font
something like red you know just to see
it may work it may not work there's
nothing wrong with experimenting with
this kind of stuff I'm also going to
scale these up so they fill the frame a
little bit more
let's bring the same spotlight here and
let's make Jena cast a shadow
across the same spotlight at the very
end here
and we'll see how that looks let's go
ahead and preview we'll save and preview
this
[Music]
watch this kind of frame-by-frame action
to see if things are working or not
working
you
[Music]
okay so I'm digging how it's starting to
look I'm not totally sure if the lights
are gonna work for me or not
sometimes these lights and shadows
sometimes I don't we're gonna go ahead
and leave it in there for now but I do
want to change this background the the
tan is really throwing me off so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go to effect I
am going to go to channel I'm gonna
invert it so already it's a little bit
more interesting right just by inverting
that background image and then I'm also
going to make it black and white so the
color correction black and white there
we go alright so looking a little bit
better then you know the types a little
bit hard to read there but I think it's
okay for now
we're also going to change our
geometries I'm gonna select layer five
I'm gonna select layer 15 and 18 these
are all our geometry layers and let's
just set them to an overlay mode and see
how those look so that's it's even more
interesting right so now that that
geometry is there but it's not so
in-your-face right it's it's it's more
of like it's a piece of that background
which is what I want okay
so again like I said the type is a
little bit hard to read so I'm going to
select all three pieces of type here and
I'm just gonna scale them up let's just
bring them up just a little bit maybe
125 percent you know not not too bad
still a little bit hard to read um I
think that might be the shade of red
that they are so maybe a little bit
brighter red that's a little bit easier
to read that's not too bad let's also
try and colorize this background a
little bit a thousand ways you can
colorize this background what I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna create a new solid
I'm gonna call it gradient click okay
and I'm going to go to let's see here
we're going to go to generate and we're
going to do a gradient ramp and we're
just going to we're gonna make the
bottom block we're gonna make the top
maybe like an olive color
something like so and let's just set
this to overlay as well so now that
background is much much darker the type
really pops now let's play around a
little bit with the position here so if
we bring down the top is gradient ramp
you can see we're starting to get some
real life here okay so now look at how
this looks now compared to where it was
a minute ago right much more interesting
this also makes me want to select all
the type here and let me just show you a
trick here if I change the color let's
say the types all gonna be yellow so now
I can see all my time when it's all
yellow um if I just want to go to the
first one say hey select this label
group it's gonna select all three pieces
of type and now they're all selected
without me having to individually select
them let's go back again let's make it
just a slight bit darker again so
perfect I really really like that was
all so let's just select all of them
again label group and let's just space
them out just slightly so I'm just
taking the tracking here and just kind
of space them out to maybe like 50 um
you know if you're really diving into
the typography of a project you really
should take each piece of type
separately and you know work on the
tracking and the position of all the
letters a great example is this type
right here you can see the TOB the
spacing between all those is pretty good
the space between the B and the Y is too
much again the space between the s and
the Y and the y in the K is too much
compared to the E&S right so these are
things you have to look at when you
really get down to nitty-gritty design
but for this well we'll leave it as is
also I want to bring up this sacred
geometry back here so it's a little bit
brighter okay and an easy way to do
that's just command D duplicate it and
there it is right so now it's a little
bit easier to see I could go to the
first geometry here let's see what this
looks it let's do the same thing with
this command D you know that's actually
a little bit too much in my face I'm
gonna
just bring down the opacity of that one
and let's go this last one or you add
right here and let's just duplicate that
one now let's bring down the opacity of
that one as well something like that let
me just check this other one I think
this one still works for me pretty well
[Music]
okay so a couple things right off the
top is one is this I don't want to see
this gradient back there so all we need
to do is create a new solid here and
what let's call this background and
we're just gonna make it pure black and
we're just gonna bring into the back
everything right here so that kind of
solves that problem no there is still a
line here but we're gonna fix that when
we add some like digital glitchyness to
this piece in the next video so I'm
gonna lock that background and you can
see here I always try to keep the audio
track at the very very bottom of my
stack because once I have the audio
track in here I don't really need to
mess with it much and it just needs to
be out of the way so it's typically
always at the very bottom of my stack or
at the very top locked and out of the
way okay and the one other quick thing I
wanted to do on this was I want to
change this grid wall I just want to
change it to oh let's try it overlay as
well that might make things too dark
yeah things got really dark all of a
sudden so I don't want that to be overly
imma go back to screen when I add my
final color effects to this I will help
kind of you know blend in it'll help
blend in this to make it look a little
bit better but one thing I do want to do
here is I want to scale this puppy down
so let's do that let's bring the
position
maybe forward and zSpace
now you see when I bring it too much
forward so now the light is getting cut
off of this and I really want to watch
that
so let's actually let's go ahead and
scale it back up a little bit here back
in space little bit you can see oh so
right there as I bring it forward it
cuts off even more of that texture right
so it just depends how much you want to
see of that texture in that light so
something like that it's pretty
interesting mm-hmm yeah I really like
that a lot so that works for me I'm
still not sold on the on the red type I
think that that might have to change a
little bit so I think that works for me
so that's gonna wrap up this video
lesson on adding some motion into the
overall design or overall idea at
execution and we're going on here
that we have going on here for red robot
okay is this the title sequence for red
robots emotion test sequence for red
robot and it's really coming along it
starting looking really nice
so in the next video we are going to
focus in on adding what I call that
final polish okay and that final polish
is what really brings this piece to life
it's adding those final effects those
final looks things like that it's just
gonna just bring this piece to a whole
nother level because if you look at
where we started in video 1 compared to
this video this is at another level
right but watch where we go with video
number 3 so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna move on to the next video
it's come up to you know in a few days
you're gonna see it show up but in the
meantime I want you to leave me a
comment again just like last time or
send me an email with a question let me
know you know what do you think what are
your questions what are your concerns
were where'd you get caught up what can
I help you solve what problem could help
you solve with this because so many of
you have trouble getting from idea to
execution and that's what I'm trying to
teach you in this mini masterclass so
please leave me a comment or shoot me an
email let me know what you think until
then I'll see you next time I'm Cameron
and
this is motion science